Randy Weingart you know her she is the
president of the the teachers union and
here she is saying she's very upset that
the College Board which that you know
they handle these AP classes she's very
upset that they caved to scary Ron
DeSantis you know you know first saw
what the College Board did and let me
just confess I am an AP Gov teacher I
have fought but not African-American
studies but I bought a pic of
um and so I was disappointed as I said
that day with what the College Board had
taken out but let me just say this
this curriculum was in place
in three um Miami high schools and
DeSantis took it out hold it out and
those kids in those three high schools
have lost out and now because the
College Board has said to DeSantis you
have defamed us or scapegoated US or
whatever else they said this weekend in
their letter what is DeSantis doing now
he's saying well maybe I'll take out all
of the College Board classes so the
point is there has been politics
involved here and this is the point
we've tried to make throughout which is
stop the politics in schools let us
teach children and let us make sure that
kids particularly these high school kids
have this kind of elective that that
would be really good in this country
right now in terms of African-American
studies and that's what DeSantis is
trying to stop and I'm sorry that the
College Board got in the midst of this
and didn't see who he was but I think
let's watch what DeSantis does right now
he's treating the College Board like he
has treated Disney as if he alone makes
decisions about the educational needs of
kids as opposed to teachers and parents
oh so she was disappointed because she
wanted uh AP African-American studies to
teach gender queer theory if you were to
t you know I took AP Government I think
it was I think it was American history
or AP Government I don't remember even
the title but I took it in 12th grade I
think I got three college credits
something like that I had to take a test
at the end and you have to pass the test
so that you get those college credits
but they weren't trying to indoctrinate
us we learned about things like the
separation of powers the Constitution
the Declaration of Independence all of
those old documents that we are founded
upon it was pretty good my teacher was
Mr Gessner he was fantastic one he was
the guy loved the guy I absolutely loved
the guy
um so there she is and she's saying well
I'm an AP teacher too I teach apgov well
apgov is wildly different than this
nonsense but of course she's not going
to address what's actually and this is
exactly what they did on The View the
other day they never address what's
actually in any of the things they just
go with the bumper sticker thing don't
say gay well I'm gonna say gay nobody's
telling an to say gay lady
[Music]
foreign